vous avez pensé sur la compagnie gol non
écoutez si vous danser avec moi pourquoi
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
avec quel animateur tu aurais pu te
laisser tenter sur l'île de la tentation
et un joaillier défi aussi un chouette
photo
pierre ménès permet de ce nom sans
rigoler que possible parce qu'on se
marre aux mains vous auriez pu vous
marrer avec le gars avec le gorille
licha vous animez quand même jamais si
jamais il est lâche et les traits sous
scellés salloukh informaticiens ca c
[Musique]
et bien nous aussi on va faire tout de
suite le grand concours des chroniqueurs
c
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le grand concours des chroniqueurs je
suis l'animateur
il faut entre de bata nom de bâtard je
vais vous poser sur un complexe que bien
sûr bande de bâtards j'ai une question à
chacun
vous êtes sur une île déserte vous devez
en embrasser un ce serait qui sur la
bouche alors y'en a que là je trouve et
je les dis déjà je trouve que de leur
dire c'est quand même pénible ce qui
rend ce mot que moi pujadas je trouve un
certain charme et n'est pas dans votre
truc c'est vrai que j'aime bien mais
david et l'algae sous la table les vieux
scénario de film érotique un jour madame
rousseau a réussi l'autre vous avez des
problèmes je vais regarder votre antenne
madame rose
oui
je vais vous montrer c'est quoi l'amour
voilà
ah oui regardez de sebourg câbles
blindés sur le tableau
j'ai démarré pas avec du sud et j'ai
suivi par à tunis
[Musique]